like I said we'll just move on
now her
oh
do you think she smells like mushrooms
is that a that's a German Shepherd right
because they have the best like scent
scientist
this is actually a brilliant idea to
have dogs that can smell it out so you
don't have to use those buzzers from the
fredra
oh wait
look at how great he is
not like another panic attack
starting down if it's a German Shepherd
or not
oh what a good boy
oh no in the adrenaline you don't feel
it I guess that like aggressive stab
don't pull it out you're not supposed to
pull it out you're not supposed to pull
it out you're not supposed to pull it
out oh it's like a base it's a baseball
bat
Joe
oh don't touch it oh baby open your eyes
infection open your eyes Joe you're
gonna get up
that's like Simba in The Lion King oh no
oh no I can't stand those scenes welcome
back to New rockstars The Last of Us
episode six Ken is here a show where I
finally felt safe for about 40 minutes
of this episode run time for once and
hey this is the most joyous episode I
called my mom I called my mom and I said
mom wake up it's a good day it's a good
day safe episode uh this is the break
room Our Daily Show that keeps you
updated on all the nerdy news that you
need to know and today we're talking All
About Last of Us so grab some family and
saddle up do not fall off as we dive in
I'm Jessica Clemens and with us today is
Brandon Barrick oh hello I just want to
get a drink at the Tipsy Buffalo what a
good name for a barn I love it that was
my nickname in college and Anna vanston
everybody loves contractors
I could hear my mother from across the
country yelling like no not contractors
she's had a rough experience doing some
Renovations oh okay does that make sense
uh as a reminder for this first part of
the episode we will be spoiler free
except for you know what you've watched
of this show so far but we won't be
talking about anything that happens in
the games or anything happens in part
two or anything that we might know about
the future of this show so we'll just
stick to what we know about this show as
it has rolled out so far we recommend if
you haven't played the games to avoid
reading the comments if you don't want
to be spoiled and if you're in the
comments try not to be so spoilery or a
dog will come and smell it on you they
can smell when you give out spoilers
it's a German Shepherd it is a German
Shepherd uh there are a few
foreshadowing moments in this episode
for folks that have played the game
before but we'll be leaving those out of
the episode recap and we'll cover them
later we'll give you lots of warnings
before we talk about game spoilers or
spoilers for the future so you'll be
warned about that but for now this
episode begins with a reminder of what
happened last week why why Craig Mason
we saw it we lived through that trauma
we don't have to see it again we cut to
three months later they're making some
progress and suddenly it's winter that's
how Seasons work folks Joe interrogates
a couple in their cabin and asks for
some directions this is my favorite
couple in the apocalypse I want to live
there I want to live with you yeah they
were great you may recognize uh
character actor Graham green who played
Marlin who's a Native American actor
who's been in like everything he was in
like Dances with Wolves and Maverick
he's going to be in the upcoming Echo
series uh we saw him at d23 great I mean
just so many good quippy lines I love
that they've been there long before the
apocalypse uh and even though they're on
guard like the woman couldn't help but
like give them soup especially she's got
a little girl uh and she's got a map
that he's like holy hell just great they
were so great I love them it's been nice
to have an episode where I I love how
much Ellie curses but it's been
addressed a lot in this episode they're
like you have a mouth on you well like
how like growing up in fedra in this
awful place in the Boston QC you got a
much more of an edge than you do if you
have like a nice Community to be a part
of uh this couple does have some bad
news though anywhere there used to be
people you can't go there anymore and
the best advice on how to go west is to
go east and they warn Joel and Ellie
about a group of people murdering humans
and infected west of the river they've
never seen them but they just see the
bodies floating down also it's important
to note they have seen no sign of the
fireflies and that's what you know Joel
and Ellie are searching for on their way
out at least steals a rabbit and Joel
rapidly becomes an old man with some
intense chest pains uh us all aging men
out there cannot identify with that yeah
yeah it's like that's me going up two
flights of stairs I'm like this is it
leave me here leave me here uh despite
the warning Joel and Ellie continuous
into Wyoming the show has started
dropping more and more hints that Joel's
care for Ellie is growing and he's
fighting it oh yeah there's lots of
little like parent moments like put that
down or get down from there yeah your
neck they're so close now and it's so
sweet to see and then
go ahead Jessica I was gonna say well
shall make it to Father's Day and it
won't right there's three episodes so I
don't think it will at night Joel duct
tapes his boot they've been traveling on
foot for months now Ellie shares a drink
and her passion for space travel with
Joel shout out Sally Ryan I just want to
point out here okay this is more Michael
Collins replacement okay the name she
drops are Neil Armstrong Buzz Aldrin
Michael Collins was also a part of
Apollo 11. he didn't get to land on the
moon but he was in The Command Module
flying it around okay then they dropped
gym level which is Apollo 13 if you were
a member of that film an actual
historical event and then this is the
moment I really like Joel guesses that
her favorite astronaut is Sally Ride I
assume because that's who his daughter's
like favorite astronaut was and I
thought that was like a really touching
moment because that's how he knew that
she liked Sally Ride Sally Ride an
awesome astronaut by the way I feel bad
because as soon as they said it I was
like who's Sally right
um I'm I'm not a history buff when it
comes to our astronauts uh but you are
so thank you for that also an
interesting detail they have a fire here
because they're in the middle of nowhere
and less worried about the people
finding them which I thought about a lot
during that episode yeah
I was like I guess there's no one there
because there was also not that many
trees so you would see that fire from a
very far distance right but I think they
imagine because like before they're
traveling along a Highway uh a charted
path and if people were also traveling
they would see the smoke but I think in
this instance they're like oh we're on
Horseback or we're walking around the
middle of nowhere I think we're okay uh
to like do a fire here because there's
like no one around searching for people
out here no one would kill those two
anyway who would want to kill them would
want to kill them kill them I would uh
not I wouldn't I would never kill Ellie
I love her Ellie mentions her concern
about the vaccine and her inability to
save Sam and is really sad Joel goes
into dad mode and reassures Ellie if
Marlene says they can do it they can do
it and offers to take both watches he
falls asleep this time with the good ear
still up but Ellie takes the second
watch yeah I don't know if that's just
showing like I've been learning and like
he kind of acknowledges that he's mad
but he's like also very proud you can
see it in his face any kind of like nods
to say thank you for like you know
letting me get some sleep that he
probably really needs so let me see it
at the end of the episode how much that
trust has grown when she's like done
he's like gun get that gun get that gun
girl uh they continue towards Jackson
and pass a dam that will be familiar to
game players Ali asks if it makes
electricity and Joel says yeah don't ask
me how I don't have a clue literally
what every gamer was thinking like how
oh wow uh this is a small change after
Ellie called Joel's Bluff about the
siphon uh in episode four there's also a
great reference which she says damn very
funnily and he references Bill
Livingston uh the author of our favorite
pun book They're circled quickly by a
group of Raiders question mark we don't
know who they are with a dog that can
smell infected people the dog clears
Joel and moves on to Ellie there's an
interesting thing to note here we saw in
the the opening clip there the camera
holds on Joel Ellie is being searched
and we get that same kind of sound
design we did in episode one when Joe
was being held up by the federal guard
and he's waiting to see the results
foreign
it's like the blood is rushing in his
head I mean here we see him physically
like having a panic attack it's a nice
like mirroring of what happened in
episode I was like do you think he gets
that sound design when he's scared yeah
and I think it was just like reminding
the audience of where his headspace is
and like is he thinking like I can't
fight all of these people like one guy
he could take right and surprise they
had him Put the gun down right right he
doesn't have his gun he can't rush 10
people on Horseback all putting guns at
him right
with that attitude you have a Winner's
attitude uh but as this is Mo as this is
happening Maria hears Joel is looking
for his brother her ears perk up uh and
that's their ticket into Jackson baby
what a town what a beautiful Town
go ahead and okay I'm not saying more
Johnny Cash man how comforting was it to
spend some time
I I there's so many instances which this
is why I wouldn't make for a good
television show I would have stayed I
would have stayed and Frank all over
again where they leave like the next
morning it's like spend a week it's been
two weeks and honestly kick back
a free pre the pandemic I was like this
is
the association where the weather
Channel communism baby I love that like
don't even don't question it it's
communism and it's working great yeah
that moment was great where he was like
it's not communism yeah it's communism
that's the uh America baby I was in the
military Tommy peeking out right there
she was like no it is communism I also
just love I love her I love her being
like no shut up shut up
um Joel and Tommy reunite and I love
that Tommy is still working construction
when Joel gets into the town I mean was
that sorry for a second that kind of
looked like a Gallows they were building
I thought it was I thought it was I
thought it was was it not I don't know
it was I just like that was the first
thing I noticed was like oh this feels
like a Gallows or something I thought
they were making something bad
I thought they were becoming phendra
um okay we got I mean they have a jail
yeah
you could go in there that's how they
scare they scare the kids Ellie stares
on as Joel and Tommy Embrace a glance at
how important family can be to someone
something she's never had the like look
of pain in her eyes when she's like you
know she's thinking like he's never
hugged me like this I've never seen the
soft side of Joel I was also thinking it
was more like I was thinking when she
did that it was more fear that like oh
he's gonna leave yeah yeah she's like oh
he's found something else to like he's
found here
don't worry they're gonna have a fight
oh yeah Tommy asked Joel what he's doing
here and Joel says he's come here to
save him damn it Tommy why did you stop
calling Joel back yeah that was rude as
hell that was rude as hell Tommy that
was rude at lunch Ellie gets stared down
by a local and is immediately hostile
and we learned that Tommy and Maria are
married with a kid on the way I also
love to hear how like we see Ellie's
classic fast eating and Joel's kind of
picked it up a little bit too he's he's
eating a little quick too
they're both hungry and they're both
yeah they're like looking yeah
oh prison rules [__] uh I do I love
Ellie's Edge man
[Music]
plus you get a good dog to round them up
who can smell fungus that's great uh I
guess everyone in this episode is going
to have like a super weird relationship
with family and new family Dynamics
that's why they called it kin baby how
about we get over it and everyone just
stays in Jackson and we in the show and
everyone is happy I mean this would be a
great ending of the show the end they
live and they got a house
that's why I'm not made for television I
literally would have stayed I would have
been like this is great we just trade
and I work and I help you guys let's do
it I love it Maria gives Joe and Ellie a
tour and refers to Jackson as a commune
the Texas boys of course flenching that
but she's totally right Joel and Tommy
share a drink and Tommy breaks the news
that he's not going to Colorado with
Joel it's too dangerous and he has a
family now Marie is pregnant uh sorry
Joel you don't count as family like your
old family your old murder family I got
new we're kicking in a new family one is
silver and the others yeah right right
Tommy asked about both Tess and Ellie
and Joel tells a double lie here he says
Ellie is just looking for her family
she's some family of some firefight big
wig and Tessa is fine
she's not fine she's peaceful she got a
kiss before she died I guess uh Joel
walks outside and after more chest pain
he sees a woman with hair just like
Sarah who probably would be just about
her age if Sarah was still alive and she
has a kid and it's Christmas there's
just oh man that is heavy stuff they
also put up a little tree they put up a
little tree I was afraid I was afraid uh
Joel was about to lick that flagpole and
get his tongue stuck
but it was complete sense Brandon I was
waiting for that scene to also happened
I thought he was like you know I wonder
if this is true about it who double dog
dared me
okay so Ellie gets a shower and a diva
cup for Maria pretty clutch but please
find some boiling water to toss that
thing into first because it looks hella
old hopefully unused yeah I mean not
hard to find boiled water also I'm an
idiot I didn't think about the diva cup
that's much smarter than looking for
other hygiene products all the time
right easily easy
um I'm a dummy you guys are more
advanced on the show Good job this is
why you can't be on the show yeah oh
yeah somebody using different and Maria
and Tommy's house she spots a little
Shrine to Sarah and Kevin a
three-year-old that Maria lost in the
first few days of the outbreak
it's sad uh this is the first time Ellie
hears that Joel had a daughter she also
gets a super [__] purple coat from
Maria it's eggplant
purple
and it's kind of acting like an [__]
about it no thank you at all I feel like
even with Ellie sarcasm she isn't
usually rude like this she's been
extremely mean this entire time I kind
of like it uh maybe she can feel Joel
looking to pull away or similarly
getting attached and worried she'll lose
like she lost her parents Marlene Etc
everybody right um I but also I just
think she's keeping her guard up and I
love that like it's not effective when
it's like you're outnumbered there's a
million people here there's only you and
Joel but like I like that she's still
like well Tommy's an idiot yeah I'm not
an idiot yeah I mean she you know is
very much has always been a survivalist
and if she comes out of the shower and
all of her stuff is missing like all her
clothes are missing I can't imagine
she'd be like let's just take my stuff
yep do you think it's kind of like a
little quiet quitting too right like
she's if I'm an [__] this town won't
let me stay here and they'll kick Joel
and I out and then maybe Joel can't just
drop me off here right I think it's a
little bit of that like I'm gonna be so
on edge and I mean she has a point too
like Maria was there to like kill them
and she's like we're looking for Tommy
you know I think I think she's allowed
to be on edge I did I did really like
the moment too when Maria's like cutting
her hair and she's like oh did you use
the cut hair and she's like I was a
district attorney well no wonder you're
better
that was like a great moment I was like
that was a district attorney check
yourself uh for a second holy [__]
there's a movie theater in Jackson and
they're screening everyone's favorite
film the 1977 Richard Dreyfuss movie The
Goodbye Girl everybody's favorite
kids are loving it oh they love the
little 70s Richard Dreyfuss baby I mean
couldn't they have found like something
from the early 2000s these poor kids
could have been watching like Finding
Nemo that came out in May 2003. are you
the one that collects physical media
yeah yeah you would have been good but
watch these people not carry their
physical media around with them Brandon
so they're like oh I have a a weird uh
Caddyshack maybe that's all that was
like I mean I assume they've watched
everything that was left in that movie
theater and so they're back on the cycle
again uh but yeah was this I this was an
actual movie I think this was the barn
wasn't it oh yeah but I mean probably
there's somewhere where they found a
real film there must have been a movie
theater somewhere close unless it's the
only film they have and they watch it
every week that is the that is actually
something good to know is like that
someone saved like a projector a film
projector or just or a digital one it
could be well I also don't know when
yeah digital projectors became more
common and they started digitally
sending movies to theaters and there was
no physical media that's a good question
but that might have been later in the
2000s I don't know who invented uh
Lumiere
it's his fault Joel tells uh Tommy that
Ellie is immune and kind of breaks down
asking for his help this is a very
vulnerable moment for Joel he's also
drinking again man hasn't got his hand
on a pill bag in like months he's joking
hard he needs them I need some pills all
I got is this really good whiskey he's
getting good whiskey though he can tell
it tastes good I like the little look on
his face he's like oh you guys actually
have good whiskey I've been drinking
this crap out of my uh yeah just like
some juice yeah like a little tape label
on the bottle which made me think have
been making it like they've been
distilling their own whiskey there great
stuff uh he tells Tommy about Tessa's
death and how he's slowing down and
worried about Ellie's safety and is
making him feel like his heart is
stopped this guy is like in full anxiety
panic attack mode PTSD all over the
place then we get the most emotionally
devastating lie in this episode he talks
about how he's not sleeping and he and
when he does wake up he quote I just
know that when I wake up I've lost
something I'm failing in my sleep I mean
we've all had those dreams where you
have your work dreams or your you know
your your career dreams and it's a mess
and you wake up and you're like oh thank
God that's not real uh have those dreams
and then wake up and you're in like a
post-apocalyptic world with infected and
you're trying to keep this girl alive
like just Panic upon Panic no relief
from this Panic yeah uh crazy and I kind
of thought that you know he he said even
before the show started uh Craig Mason
and truckman that he was going to be
Joel is going to be more vulnerable he
was going to feel his age more and I
kind of thought that was a little bit
self-contained like oh it makes him just
more vulnerable instead of the video
game invincibility yeah but it's also
been building up to him feeling like
this is the reason why he has to right
get Ellie off of him but you know he's
kind of unburden himself with Ellie
because he's scared that he's getting so
invested in her and he's so afraid he's
gonna be the cause of her death again
and Kim bringing up that like I'm old
I'm slow I didn't hear that guy I
couldn't stop that guy she had to kill
this guy because of me because I'm
failing I'm failing uh that's heavy
stuff I also love you know we see him
trying to fix his shoe uh with the hand
the hand that he punched the Federation
with that it has the hairline fracture
it's still a problem for him and I think
the shoes are a good metaphor here he's
putting duct tape on it earlier a quick
fix to a problem when the real solution
is replace the boots my guy and Tommy
look to community you can't do it all
yourself you have to like look up for
help remember he thinks he's Tommy
Savior and here he is begging Tommy to
save him he's like I'm done I'm old
that's the stuff that I think mentally
Joel will come full circle with and he
has because he's like yeah get the gun
he's now realizing that because he's
like I'm getting too old and it's like
well Ellie's getting older and she's
very sure she does so she'll be fine I
mean even the old couple in the cabin
points out like who's this little psycho
like they can tell right away this girl
ain't right uh Tommy does agree to take
Ellie on after he hears the whole story
he's like I'll do it uh but Ellie has
overheard this conversation we later see
which is very interesting yeah Joel and
Ellie have a heartbreaking conversation
that has pulled almost word for word
from the game Joel changes his mind
about taking Ellie after flashing back
to a Christmas with Sarah he's getting
so soft he's getting soft he didn't
sleep again and he's like uh I was like
I tried I was gonna leave a half hour
ago but I couldn't
plot twist those are all therapy horses
these communist horses this is Animal
Farm baby the sheep and the horses well
that's good two legs bad oh my God they
leave for the University of Eastern
Colorado and get there without a hitch
but there are no signs of fireflies at
the college just some monkeys a group of
Raiders arrives on the campus and Joel
and Ellie try to make it to their horse
but Joel's bad hearing gets him again
and one of the Raiders sneaks up behind
him Joel takes a gnarly wound to an
abdomen from a broken baseball bat that
I thought was a ship from prison I
thought it was a princess but Brandon
was like Jessica's a baseball bat and
re-showed it to me it is before snapping
the neck of his assailant yeah he
straight up just straight up choke holds
yeah this is the first time that he
choked someone or kept well he snatches
his name but choked someone like that
like in the game yeah I think so I we
haven't really seen him do that before
he's gotten in tussled by that move yeah
like very game I don't know I don't I've
never done it but I can tell you it's
probably physically so hard to break
someone's neck like that without
training so I was like he's just doing
this pure like adrenaline I could do it
and I bet he said it a few times right
you can do it to chicken just grab a
chicken
try it on me right now cause I'll kick
your ass
yeah you see him break the baseball back
on their tree and like Joel grabs him
and that's how the stabbing happens it's
really quick but it's not to be that
person also have you ever uh hit hit a
tree with a baseball bat that
reverberation hurts so bad that that
[__] would break off so quick or you
drop it so quick uh I used to smash uh
mailboxes keep going this girl's a
problem this little psycho here uh so
the two take off on Horseback and outrun
the other Raiders with LA doing some
sweet behind the back back taking shots
at him uh Joel slips off the back of the
horse and we in the episode with Ellie
pleading for Joel to open his eyes damn
it Joel she you can't [__] do this
with she can't [__] do this without
you Joe okay you've got to get it
together the credits roll on a cover of
Depeche Mode's never let me down again
the same song that Closed episode one
danger time we're in danger uh what an
episode uh it was nice to kind of have
no infected at all this happened episode
very interesting and also like uh not a
lot of it was nice to kind of feel safe
but this episode is titled kin and we
see a lot of family Dynamics in this
episode that I think we should talk
about uh for our first point today Ellie
asked Joel what we're going to do after
all this and seems sad when she sees
Joel and Tommy getting a reunion right
and Joel is very quick to kind of push
off this like we idea like the old what
do you got a mouse in your pocket we're
not we're not a Wii uh Joel seems
jealous of Tommy's new family Mr I miss
the referees is that what's that from oh
if you ever say like oh we're gonna go
to the store you're talking to someone
like oh we're gonna go to the store and
you say to them like what do you got a
mouse in their pocket we're not going to
the store
joke
it's not it's all right
are you having to meet me or is that a
mouse in your pocket exactly exactly
Josie's jealous of Tommy's new family
with Maria and the fact that she has a
child on the way Tommy also kind of just
dipped out and didn't say like hi I'm
leaving uh murderer I gotta go uh I also
want to Circle back kind of on that
sound design thing we talked about in
the moment he thinks Ellie is going to
be torn apart by the dog this kind of
compounding idea family and the danger
that they're in uh which part do you
want to talk about first let's talk
about like all the family Dynamics in
this episode right this idea that Joel
is so afraid of getting close to Ellie
and it keeps every time I feel like he
gets close he backs off and then he gets
closer than he was before it's like uh
two one step forward two steps back in a
way like he can't help himself but
getting close closer and closer uh to
Ellie yeah well you you see a bunch of
different like different types of
families in this episode you start out
with the two people who are just living
on their own uh seemingly Child free I
guess they could have I don't know there
could be a child on the woods somewhere
they don't want to mention for their
safety right we have fur babies in the
rabbits
um you see so they're living on their
own you have uh Joel and Ellie obviously
you have uh Tommy and his wife and now
who is pregnant now so that's their own
family you have the family that is the
commune and they're one big family
well I think I think this episode really
shows the strength of family like we
were saying earlier right the power of
Communism but like the power of a
commune in a family where you share and
you trade and you're all working
together towards I think it's a goal
like both the small example and the
large example point to it's a it's a red
flashing light for Joel where it's like
hi you need family you can't do this on
your own and he's starting to realize
that too one family I think it's just
like you need support uh even in your
shoe right you need something good shoes
you need the support
um I I'm it's so I think Tommy's is more
interesting because it's the situation
of like you had a daughter and do you
remember how much that took like a toll
on you when she passed like I'm gonna be
that Dad now and I have to protect my
child I can't go to Colorado and he's
just like I need you to like do this one
favor for me and he's like I you I I you
and it's also the fact that like Joel
thought like I'm protecting my little
brother and it's like well he's not a
little brother anymore he has a family
now do you when what Tommy says to Joel
to kind of like
win that argument if you will when he's
like just because this happened to you
doesn't mean like I have to do what you
say right I it's it was a it was a sharp
dagger that was the first stepping that
Joel took this episode is that fair for
Tommy to say that he later apologizes
right but was it right for Tommy to say
that is he right well it's that that's
the interesting part is like as a little
sibling
um it's like if you had your entire life
your brother looking over you and doing
all these things and telling you what
you did wrong right it's like you were
the mess even before the pandemic he was
like yeah my brother's in jail again
he's always doing those bad things and
it's like looking down on him and then
finally standing his own ground finding
his own meeting a woman falling in love
getting married having a child and he's
like no I can't do this like I get you
always put this on me and I'm not gonna
take it like I can't do that for you you
have to do this yourself I don't think
it was like right but in the moment of
being like a little sibling and having
all this on your shoulder it probably
came out as kind of word vomit and an
honest truth because I mean there's a
difference between what's true and
what's right or kind I have to say you
know and I think his his words were like
time doesn't stop or like time can't
stop or something like that which watch
time that whole Motif oh yeah um but you
know I I think it was also a bit of a
wake-up call like again he can be right
and it might not be nice to hear yeah
like I think the epidemic probably made
people more blunt too
there's no room for Courtesy social
mores right like here's and also they're
like on a commune where they trade so
they're probably bartering that's like a
lot more aggressive they're probably
like look here this is what you're gonna
get like I'm gonna just be honest
what did you think of like the illusion
of sheep in this episode I kind of like
the idea like we talked about this with
Bill and Frank some too is this a good
idea for this town to wall themselves
off and stay the way Society was I mean
they have formed a commune in their
sharing and all that but like are they
safer like this or unlike Bill and Frank
they're going out there and killing
people so it's like they're making and
everyone notices they're they're
watching the area they're very aware
when someone comes into their territory
from far away I don't know if they're uh
going out and killing seems like on the
attack like on the offense I think
they're like defending their little uh
their little Paradise which I mean it's
just as dangerous as I guess we're kind
of living now in regular Society because
it is the most close thing to normalcy
that we've seen in this show in a
community and I guess in a difference
from Bill and Frank they've welcomed
people in
as needed I guess some people already
living there but it sounds like when
people walk up they have the dog the dog
doesn't kill you we'll talk right I
think that uh what I was from the first
family that we see in the that live
alone they're like yeah that place is
dangerous that's where you're gonna die
it's just a bunch of innocent people
have been killed so I think everyone on
the outskirts of the city is like we
just don't go over there
so I think it's just like killing not
killing but I guess like keeping a
barrier and making people because even
she said in the episode of something
like making them believe what did she
say she said something that was really
like is not inspirational but like
moving about like
we're not killing for like sport we're
just sending a message that like don't
come over here they're pretending to be
it sounds like the way that they're
killing people who are a threat to them
they they make it seem that like
whoever's in these walls they're really
bad people this is their their mean
they're vicious they're it's not like
they could be mutilating these bodies in
a way to like scare off people that are
like I don't even want to mess with this
look what they did to this body I found
like but they're her thing is like
that's not us on the inside that's what
we're projecting on the outside yeah uh
to keep us safe and it's like the things
we do to keep each other safe it works
uh I I also really found it interesting
in Tommy and Joel's conversation as we
talk about family the family they had
before when it was like Tommy Joel Tess
and whoever else was involved in the
little murder crew it sounds like Tommy
was never in on it as much he was just
going along are you or is that something
Maria has kind of come to terms with
where she's like well Joe made Tommy do
all that stuff oh just judging off I
mean
yeah he says it's not you it's we we did
those things so I mean I don't know
Maria's side of it we get that but we
hear it straight from the horse's mouth
but I think it's because he feels guilty
and so he's like again he's like treated
like a little brother all the time so I
was like I took it as like oh maybe he
was the first one to bring up because
Tess and Joel were already together as a
unit right Tommy was by himself he
didn't have another person so it was
just being like hey maybe this isn't the
right idea and Tess and Joel being like
this is all we can do well and it is as
Joel has said before Tommy or was a
follower right he was always looking for
something to follow a cause or something
like that and Joel may have manipulated
that in a way and being like Tommy you
have to come murder these people with us
I mean this is what we need to do to
survive Anna's still right though he did
do it so hopefully it doesn't make him a
good person man he still did it so
you're still at fault who knows what we
would do uh in play dead kill people we
know Anna we're doing the apocalypse
what would I do in the apocalypse I
would go to nerd riot.shop and buy one
of our brand new shirts okay inspired by
The Last of Us babe let me be clear I
would wear one of our shirts
look for the light look for the light
and it's not the light show killing you
in the apocalypse you got crackers
you're dead uh but yeah go to
nerdrive.shop pick up this shirt we got
a lot of awesome other merch on the site
we've got Ant-Man and wasp quantumania
merch available on the site right now
yeah there we go uh you can get that
that's opening this weekend if you
haven't already seen it uh but check it
out it's a great way to support the work
we do here at new rockstars uh lots of
great merch options there nerdrive.shop
check it out support the channel rock
some great merch and have a great time
also we've talked about it before with
this lovely jacket Joel's got a new
jacket now that he's in colder
temperatures but if you remember this
jacket this is a jacket he's also been
wearing it's he's got it under on
underneath his puffer it's from
huckberry uh the costume designers that
work on the show they got this jacket
from huckberry it's a flint and Tinder
wax canvas trucker jacket uh straight
from huckberry it's flannel line so it's
very warm as I sweat here under the
lights and it's comfy and I love it and
it's great uh it's made in the USA from
really sturdy stuff uh and it's probably
also cordyceps resistant uh but I still
have not tested that very
busy guy once the show's done I will
test it then when I when I don't have to
be here for you I have scurvy if I bite
you will it be the same uh let's I don't
know if you can get scurvy through bites
but we'll find out click the link in
this video's description to buy your own
and help support our last of us coverage
here at new rock stars uh so let's get
into like our next round a little
spoiler let's talk about some changes
from the game so if you haven't played
the games you don't want to be spoiled
anymore come back out turn don't play
the games but some spoilers coming now
so here we go some changes from the game
changes from the game the first one
right off the bat at the beginning of
the episode that couple ain't in the
game and what a great addition so good
everything they said was so good it's
gonna take a nap in her bosom I'm so
happy I mean what a lovely lovely lady
makes your soup great I mean I just love
the but we talked about the bluntness in
a post-apocalyptic world even from the
couple they have like no they love each
other it's clear but like their language
is there can you tell them the truth
I know I love it we did get that um we
talked about a little bit last time on
how the game uh Henry and Sam die and
then it does the cut to three months
later but in the game the three months
later is in the fall not the winter
um so they've changed the timeline a
tiny bit but hey
um beautiful yeah the winter Wyoming
it's beautiful
I love those mountains around the town
it looked gorgeous picturesque
uh in the game they have to fix the dam
but in this it's it's already up it's
not working in this show they uh Jackson
seems like sort of a really big
Community like a whole whole thing that
was about like 300 people or something
like that in the town a lot of a lot of
people not many people and in the game
it seems slightly smaller he says we're
we're over 20 families but when you say
over 20 such a specific number it's
probably 22. you would sail for 30 if
you had more than 30. yeah yeah exactly
exactly
um and we don't actually see Jackson in
the game Until the Last of Us Part Two
uh so it's bigger and it's uh and we see
it yeah they have a lot more going on at
this Jackson yeah yeah absolutely
um so because we don't actually see
Jackson in the first part of the game
most of the events of the episode take
place at the dam and then later at an
abandoned neighborhood that Ellie runs
away to which is another change is that
in the game Ellie overhears them talking
about her being passed off to Tommy and
and she takes off on horror
yeah I think she takes off on a horse
and they they panic and have their Joel
panics mostly and has to go find her
with Tommy and that's what her being in
danger is what makes Jules change his
mind and be like no I'm not gonna go I'm
going with you all right deep Gruff I
personally love that change uh I was
afraid they were going to do the runaway
plot line and they didn't and I also
love how they subverted like the gamer's
expectation there where it's like you
don't see her overhearing the
conversation you see her walking around
town like looking around what's going on
and I love the reveal later that she's
heard the conversation as she's reading
the journal too again Ellie with an edge
is like all I gotta worry about is boys
and what they're gonna wear well and
that was a uh pretty much shot for shot
of the game is this really all they had
to worry about
boys movies
deciding which shirt goes with which
skirt
is this really all they had to worry
about
boys movies
deciding which shirt goes with which
skirt
I'm sorry about your daughter Joel
but I have lost people too you have no
idea what loss is
everyone I have cared for has either
died or left me
foreign
[__] except for you
don't tell me that I would be safer with
someone else because the truth is I
would just be more scared
I'm sorry about your daughter Joel
but I have less people too
you have no idea what law says
everybody I have cared for
has either died or left me
everybody [__] up for you
so don't tell me that I'd be safe with
somebody else because the truth is I
would just be more scared
[Music]
you're not my daughter
and I sure as hell ain't your dad
and we are going our separate ways
you're not my daughter
I'm not sure as hell ain't your dad
foreign
we're going our separate ways
I do love they didn't do the whole
runaway thing Joel being there in the
morning was like a nice cute
sign yeah I mean really it makes sense
practically because not much happened
during like there's no reason really for
her anyway the same scene takes place
and it's just it's mostly gamer [__]
like uh have Jill shoot dangerous stuff
missions missions
um so Maria is pregnant in this one and
lost her son those are new details uh
she just chilling in the game she's just
being a little leader they gave her a
lot more agency here which I really like
also did you recognize did you recognize
uh Maria
she is from uh True Blood
did you ever watch True Blood yeah
eggs my eggs that is she still looks
great she's killing it I'm Twilight or
bust
I'm so so I'll bust uh and then oh yeah
you will not like that oh yeah you will
oh no is there a mouse in your pocket
anyway uh and and Joel's reasoning for
leaving Ellie with Tommy is different
this I mean this is in the game Joel is
not he doesn't have this big monologue
this meltdown sort of a thing he it's
more of a logical thing for him it's
like y'all you have the guys you should
go take her and finish this off also on
that real quick the panic attacks that
he's having that's like kind of a new
device for the show which I really like
that uh it's very interesting because I
mean you know having in the game would
be weird like press X to breathe slowly
I don't know but like it's a very
interesting device and I love that thing
too it's like not that he wants to get
rid of her because he's just sick of it
it's that like he knows that he's
falling in love and like he's like I've
gotta get away from this because like my
body can't handle it yeah that layer of
vulnerability and fear was so effective
and that whole monologue was probably my
favorite part of the episode I really
loved it
um so yeah as we mentioned before there
are no infected at all in this uh
including the University of Eastern
Colorado uh the way Joel gets that wound
is different in the show than in the
game broke a baseball bat in the show on
the game he falls onto a piece of rebar
it's really like shocking like it's one
of those like almost like Fallen offense
moments where he was like oh my God and
as Ellie you have to pull him off right
in the game yeah I do also like the
change of not the rebar thing because
that is a very I wanted a superhero
moment right like I think we could
believe that Joel could continue to live
from stab yeah the whole like pulling
someone off
I loved it so much I want it I just love
Gore uh I was very like oh I can't wait
to watch Ellie pull him off of this
giant slab uh we'll get into our kill
counts for this episode and it's not
gonna take too long because there's only
one death this episode Joe gets won by
strangulation and broken Nick is that
pretty powerful is that the kill of the
week that's the kill of the week here on
the last devices detail of the week
um so real quick before we wrap up this
episode and we're in full spoiler mode
now we can talk about second game we can
talk about whatever we want uh a
question I have for you both is like
something we've heard on the podcast the
after Show podcast for the show from
Craig Mason and Neil druckman is that
the creators I've talked a lot there are
still a lot of surprises in store for
people who have played the games uh and
are watching the show the next episode
of this show is called Left Behind the
title of the DLC for the game that
exists mostly in flashback but still has
some of Ellie looking for meds for Joel
we'll see what happens there what
changes to the end of the season do you
think we're gonna see I wonder if
they're going to avoid the more like
eating humans oh no when he gets Ellie
when he like is on top of her and that's
a very uh visceral moment yeah I don't
know if that's the right word but it's
just like I don't know if they're gonna
avoid that I honestly I I really enjoy
the beats in the game I wonder if sort
of the I don't know if it's a big enough
difference for them to talk about it but
I wonder if Ellie's going to kill Riley
in the game yeah um that it makes sense
right we're expecting to see a flashback
this up next episode to in the mall when
her and Riley get attacked and if in the
game she doesn't kill Riley but in the
show we know that she's killed we don't
know right she could have no problem
they love connecting things so much for
like the bread at the first episode and
the handshaking the watch it be like
yeah that is the one well this next
episode start with the image of a snowy
yes a snowy floor and a little rabbit
come hopping yes and people who know are
gonna look to the people watching the
show who don't know maybe it won't be as
gruesome as an arrow uh maybe it'll be
like oh no I was gonna say maybe it's
gonna fall into like a bear trap but
that's way worse than the narrow and do
you think as we talk about this videos
about how they're going to surprise us
are they gonna surprise us with
something very like a shocking death
that does not happen in the games like
good Tommy died put Maria die what if
could someone who we know survives in
the games not survive this season of the
show what if Riley was never this is
very stupid this is like literally Rogue
Theory what if Riley was never gonna
turn what if Riley was Joe's also oh no
he just like stayed alive and was like
should we kill him what if Riley's still
alive and has become the mega bloated
what if she is a bloater and she comes
back I followed you all the way to
Wyoming I love your new voice right it's
really it's great I don't think the
bloaters talk like that
um I I don't know I think I I if it's
not as small as shooting Riley I don't
think they changed too much about the
DLC because they've already introduced
the arcade game so it feels like they're
setting that see that specific mall
scene up I think it'd probably have to
do with the cannibals and all that and
maybe the fight and the barbecue place
or whatever I think if she did Kill ride
it it was probably with that that knife
her or her mother's knife tough stuff
here's something I noticed in uh in the
show in the the barn when they first get
there and are eating that thing and she
gives the Mean Mug to the girl could
that be Dina oh
the actress kind of kind of like the uh
the end game well there was a lot of
kind of like foreshadowing of part two
right we saw Shimmer uh who is Ellie's
horse in part two uh the cute little
pony thank you it's Gotta grow up a
little bit uh we also learned that Joel
wants to settle down and at an old
farmhouse and raise some sheep and this
is kind of what Ellie and Dina will do
in The Last of Us Part Two is she gonna
steal his idea I mean like could jolt
die this season would that be totally
insane I would I don't know that's all I
think that's a TV it's it's on the
audience for TV versus the audience for
the games if it will come across uh for
HBO Max like a good idea to kill Pedro
Pascal that quickly right I think the
big moment is his decision too and then
his decision to take her and then lie to
her like I feel like that's a good
season finale yeah yeah I do uh when he
said that sheep line I did clock and I
was like oh my God that's gonna be why
Ellie's so it's about razors yeah
adorable there it is so that is it for
this episode of the break room we'll be
back next week to discuss episode seven
but we also do the show every day live
at 3 P.M talking about all the nerdy
news you love and you all the nerdy news
that you need to know follow me at Lulu
underscore Clemons follow Brandon at
Grand Barrick follow Anna and it's Anna
vanston subscribe to the break room
wherever you get your podcast and we'll
see you Tuesday thanks for watching
goodbye
[Music]
all right
foreign
[Music]